[Applaudissements]
ja je remercie le comité d'organisation
d'avoir eu à l'intérêt à la cause
humanitaire
et de m'avoir permis d'être ici
aujourd'hui
vous allez me demander d'abord
comment je me suis lancé dans
l'humanitaire
en fait c'est parti d'un rêve un rêve de
jeunesse
évidemment moi je viens d'un pays qui
est développé déjà depuis de nombreuses
décennies
quand j'étais petite fille au regard des
souvent les reportages à la télé vous
voyez déjà
la misère
enfants qui souffraient partout dans le
monde
un enfant malnutri
n'avaient pas accès aux soins
à l'eau à l'électricité
comme nous donc ça me touchait tout ça
me touchait vraiment énormément et je me
suis dit
lawrence
ho que tu partes il faut que tu partes
aider parce que c'est pas juste en fait
pourquoi moi j'ai droit à tout et puis
que ces enfants
n'ont droit à rien quoi il ya trop de
différences
et puis j'ai grandi j'ai fait mes études
dans le social
est dans le droit qui me passionnait je
voulais absolument
aider les gens en fait donc mon idée
était déjà de devenir assistante sociale
parce que ça me plaisait de devoir de
pouvoir intervenir en fait au niveau des
gens qui étaient dans le besoin
et dans ma nature
et après bon ça ne s'est pas fait parce
que j'ai rencontré mon mari je me suis
marié
j'ai d'abord vu un enfant très
rapidement
un bébé une petite fille qui est née
j'ai partagé quelques temps avec et puis
qui est décédé très rapidement de mort
subite du nourrisson
avec d'abord une très grande douleur
parce qu' un enfant c'est tout quoi
c'est nos tripes
[Musique]
et beaucoup de difficultés au début à
surmonter cette peine
et je me suis dit il ya toujours pire
ailleurs donc laurence il faut que tu
remonte la pente
et continuer j'ai eu mon fils et puis
après encore une vie
et la vie et à continuer j'ai travaillé
dans les écoles j'ai travaillé dans
secrétariat dans l'événementiel jusqu'à
ce que je crée mon entreprise en france
dans le secrétariat partagé dans le
standard téléphonique je travaillais à
l'époque avec des médecins
je gagnais très bien ma vie
je venais de divorcer glv m4 mes enfants
mes quatre enfants tout seuls mais je
m'en sortais très bien
et puis un jour
elle personne qui est rentré dans mon
bureau
un africain je ne savais pas d'où ils
venaient
mais je me suis intéressé à lui donc
j'ai commencé à lui poser des questions
d'où il venait c'est là qu'il m'a
expliqué la guinée j'ai dit mais la
guinée je ne connais pas très bien c'est
vrai c'est pas un pays qu'on entend tout
le temps parler donc on a fait des
recherches sur internet
et là il m'a expliqué un peu son pays
qu'est ce qui s'était passé
l'indépendance et cetera
là on a vu aussi les difficultés les
enfants je voyais souvent les photos
quand on regardait les enfants qui
étaient dans la rue eddy dont il faut
que j'aille là-bas vraiment tu va
m'amener dans ton pays je veux découvrir
la guinée
et là on a organisé donc notre premier
voyage en avril 2010
et là où j'ai posé pour la première fois
mes pieds en guinée
et mai j'ai aimé ce pays parce que ya
une chaleur qu'on ne retrouve pas chez
nous
vraiment la guinée m'a très bien
accueilli
et puis c'est un très beau pays vraiment
très riche le sol est très riche
là beaucoup à faire
ce pays demande vraiment toute
l'attention du monde
quand j'ai commencé à me promener
à travers
la guinée j'ai vu tous ces enfants dans
les quartiers des enfants bord des
routes qui faisait la mendicité
les enfants qui vendait de l'eau des
bonbons des biscuits
vraiment interpellé me suis dit mais
pourquoi
et là je suis allé me promener dans les
quartiers plus pauvres
là j'ai vu vraiment la misère
et dis donc c'est bien là que je dois
être c'est là où je dois apporter mon
soutien
surtout aux enfants qui ont besoin
d'aller à l'école parce que leur place
n'est pas dans la rue
donc on est rentré on a créé notre
association
on a commencé à faire des récoltes
pour pouvoir les amener et là on avait
déjà des va et vient on venait
distribués dans les écoles dans les
orphelinats
et puis un jour en rentrant à monsieur
nous a contacté pour nous donner un bus
un minibus
me dit madame laurence je vous donne ça
mais c'est vraiment destiné pour les
enfants jeudi vous inquiétez pas je sais
ce que je veux en faire
parce que
je voyais qu'il y avait des carences en
livre surtout en guinée à ce moment là
et on avait récupéré beaucoup de livres
donc on a décidé en fait tu dors mener
ce bus par la route pour les descendre
jusqu à conakry
ont la charge et de livres et puis
d'autre à faire qu'on avait récupéré on
est partis avec deux camions parce qu'on
avait déjà un autre petit camion
hélas le 8 décembre
on est partis du sud de la france et
nous vous la partie donc à l' aventure
où là on a traversé
déjà l'espagne le maroc la mauritanie
le mali parce qu'on n'a pas dépassé par
le mali et ensuite on est arrivé en
guinée
on a mis 20 jours mais vingt jours
inoubliables
très enrichissant
est-ce qu'on a rencontré beaucoup de
gens sur la route
donc je ne pourrai jamais oublier ce
voyage et j'espère pouvoir un jour même
le refaire
on est arrivé à conakry évidemment on
n'avait plus rien dans les poches
donc on a sollicité les 7 auprès des
institutions finalement on a réussi
à avoir un soutien de l'institut
français de guinée qui a pris en charge
notre public opus
donc je les apporter au niveau du centre
culturel franco guinéen et là ils ont
mis en marche le bus qui a duré à peu
près quatre années qui venait porter à
l'époque donc les livres dans les écoles
faire des prêts quoi
après ça donc je suis revenu en france
mais je n'était toujours pas satisfaite
parce que je me suis dit bon c'est bien
on fait des va-et-vient mais en même
temps c'est pas ça ce que je voulais
c'était vraiment venir en aide à ces
enfants
de a à z
et pourquoi pas ouvrir justement un
orphelinat donc lâche je suis préparé
j'ai appelé mes enfants évidemment je
leur ai demandé leur avis et si je
quitte la france si je viens en guinée
est ce que vous en pensez
bon j'avais deux grands déjà quitté déjà
en couple pour eux c'était moi important
c'était surtout pour les plus petits
mais quand même leur réponse m'a touché
parce qu'ils m'ont dit coûte maman on
sait que c'est ton rêve donc nous tous
qui nous importe c'est au bonheur
vas-y
pas c'était la principale chose qui
m'importait le reste les gens évidemment
vous savez il ya des gens qui vous
décourage à pourquoi tu pars en afrique
a rien là par je ne sais pas quand même
la guinée y'a pas que rien n'y a pas que
des 15 en afrique raclée gens ne
connaissent pas roi
donc j'ai pas écouter les gens moi j'ai
écouté seulement mon coeur et je suis
venu en janvier 2014 évidemment c'est un
peu difficile au début parce qu'il a
fallu que je refasse mes repères et je
suis venu seul
et pas été accompagné ce coup ci parce
que mon collaborateur guinéen lui il
préfère rester en france
je suis venu vraiment à l' aventure
d'abord allé dans un quartier pauvre de
conakry pour vraiment m'imprégner en
fait de ce que vivaient les gens
donc j'ai passé trois mois dans un
quartier il y avait ni courant ni eau et
en plus c'était extrêmement précaire
mais c'est ça qui me plaisait parce que
là au moins j'ai vu ce que les gens
vivaient
et fille des dents on était dans une
concession en fait plusieurs chambres ce
sont les filles qui me mettait souvent
aller chercher l'eau parce qu'il fallait
faire le tour du pâté de maison pour
aller dans un puits
et c'est ça m'a beaucoup touché quoi
et continuer mes actions puisque j'avais
quand même cette association qui
existait déjà en france et j'ai commencé
à aller voir les orphelinats donc là je
me suis intéressé à eux pour savoir
quelles étaient leurs difficultés
comment elles géraient leur orphelinat
[Musique]
pour m'imprégner aussi de tout ce à quoi
bon
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à faire des récoltes pour
eux j'ai aussi organiser des activités
festives
parce que j'ai organisé une année à noël
pour des enfants dans un foyer les
enfants de la rue
et puis je me suis investie auprès
d'orphelinats vraiment qu'ils m'ont
touchée
jusqu'à un orphelinat ou videmment la
fondatrice est décédé la même année
et là ça m'a donné du cool envie de
vraiment ouvrir le mien
est donc lancé l'idée d'abord sur les
réseaux et auprès de mes partenaires qui
me soutenaient déjà
je leur ai dit si on ouvrait un
orphelinat parce que je crois qu'il ya
vraiment des nécessités ici ils m'ont
dit c'est une bonne idée donc on a
commencé à lancer des appels
aux dons on a ouvert une cagnotte on y
est là j'ai récolté les premiers mois de
loyer donc j'ai sillonné un peu conakry
parce que je savais déjà mon idée était
dans ma tête je voulais quelque chose
quand même qu'ils étaient assez grands
malheureusement on était obligés de
s'éloigner un peu parce que
quand on se rapproche de la ville les
prix sont un peu chers donc nous sommes
partis jusqu'à dabompa et là on a trouvé
la première maison
avait rien absolument rien on est venu
vraiment les mains dans les poches
mais il ya quand même des gens qui nous
suivait donc on commence à nous envoyer
quelques matelas et les premiers enfants
sont très vite arrivés
on a eu déjà une fratrie de
trois garçons
dont un petit garçon qui avait à
l'époque sept mois qui souffrait d'une
malnutrition
la maman n'avait pas de domicile il
était nourri au riz
ta femme a beaucoup marqué on est donc
parti évidemment consultation pour qu'il
puisse avoir un équilibre rattraper un
équilibre alimentaire
aujourd'hui ce petit garçon à 5 ans il
est toujours avec nous
et puis d'autres enfants sont arrivés
très vite en fait jusqu'à décembre 2017
on est arrivé à 35 enfants alors que
nous n'avions qu'une capacité de 25
enfants
entre temps on a eu beaucoup d'enfants
qui sont arrivés avec des problèmes de
santé
et la malnutrition en particulier
une petite fille je me souviens qu'ils
étaient venus à l'âge de dix-sept mois
qui faisait même pas 7 kg
les repenser même à ces images que je
voyais dans mon enfance en fait tous
désolés photos qu'on regardait à la télé
et on arrive si au bout de même pas un
mois elle a commencé à marcher
et puis aujourd'hui cette petite fille
ella 6 ans mais malheureusement elle a
un petit souci mental je pense qui a été
causé par la malnutrition
mais on se bat toujours pour la garder
les facultés marni vous rappelez vous
inquiétez pas je suis prêt à rester
jusqu'à leur dernier souffle
[Applaudissements]
j'habite en tous les cas toutes les
personnes parce que même si physiquement
on ne pourrait pas prendre la place
et je sais que vous pouvez faire quelque
chose un geste du ps le don de soi mais
jamais accordé un peu de temps à ses
enfants mais vous pouvez leur geste
financier matériel ou ne serait-ce que
communicative il faut informer les gens
l'enfant est la racine d'année et si
on y du bien ces enfants ils feront que
la guinée
par émerger et c'est ce qu'on vend
aujourd'hui
remercie
[Applaudissements]